About 600 million people in Africa
still don’t have reliable
access to electricity,
and energy shortages
are still a part of daily life.
Africa needs energy.
A lot of energy.
But the question is: What kind of energy?
I want to tell you a story.
My name is Chibeze Ezekiel
and I work at the Strategic
Youth Network for Development.
In 2013, the government
of my country, Ghana,
began consultations
to construct a coal plant,
a 700-megawatt coal plant,
meant to be sited at Ekumfi District,
a coastal fishing community
in the central region of Ghana.
It would have required
a 1.5-billion US dollar loan
from the China African Development [Fund].
And because Ghana has no coal reserves,
the project made a provision to import
two million tons of coal annually
from South Africa.
So I ask again,
Ghana and Africa need energy.
But what kind of energy?
In Africa, job creation and economic
opportunities are the priority,
and those were the same arguments
that were made by those
who were in support of the project.
They claimed that the project
of the coal plant
would have created jobs
for the local youth
and also expanded the economy
of the country.
But we know that coal is the most
polluting form of power generation.
We are also aware that from a purely
economic point of view,
coal is cheap.
But that is only true when we ignore
the noneconomic impact of coal.
Talk about waste water,
fly ash, emissions of sulfur
and mercury,
which would have posed serious
health and environmental risk
to the Ekumfi population.
In our part of the world,
we have people who depend on water bodies,
for bathing, for cooking,
for washing and even for drinking.
So what this means
is that it's going to have
a devastating impact
on their source of livelihood
and their life as a whole.
So this shows
that the adverse impact of coal
far outweighs the economic benefit.
Ghana and Africa need energy,
but we don't want coal to be that energy.
We managed to shut down the coal plant.
And we didn't want coal to be part
of the country's energy system.
But it did take a bit of fighting.
When we learned of the plan
to build a coal plant,
we began engaging the local communities.
We took an approach known
as the “submarine approach.”
So basically, what that means
is that we never wanted it
on social media,
we didn't go publicly,
we didn’t engage in media
on our reservations.
We spent days with the people
in our community,
talking to the chiefs, the elders,
the women groups, the youth networks,
to inquire from them
whether they have all the necessary
knowledge about the coal plant
because it is our right
to have adequate information.
And that is what we did.
We brought them information
about the negative impact
of coal in other countries.
We also had to assure them
that the jobs being promised to them
do not guarantee long-term benefits.
We also sought their input
in our advocacy campaign.
In our engagement
with the local communities,
we realized that most of them
were not even aware of the consequences
of the coal plant.
They had been assured by the promoters
that the plant will be clean
and safe for residents.
Others also had their own reservations
but didn't know who to channel them to.
We teamed up with other NGOs
working in the environmental sector.
It was only when local community
got well-informed about the plant,
to challenge the promoter’s claim,
that gave us a time
to bring out the “submarine approach.”
That was when we began
social media campaigns,
organized press conferences
and did a lot of media engagement
to also share our views
against the coal plant.
We also accompanied our campaign
against [the] coal plant
with the need for renewable energy.
And I must say that I was very surprised
when the government of Ghana
chose to back down
on the construction of the coal plant,
having heard our concerns and voices
of the local communities.
Indeed, the then-Minister of Environment
at a press conference announced
that Ghana is not
going to build a coal plant,
having signed the Paris Climate Agreement.
In 2019, [the] government released
our renewable energy master plan,
which shows a very comprehensive plan
on the development
of renewable energy in Ghana.
Among others,
the plant seeks to increase by 30 times
our renewable energy development
by 2030,
and also create more
than 200,000 jobs by 2030.
Some countries have shut down,
or are planning to shut down,
their coal plants.,
Others are frantically planning
to build coal plants.
Once a coal plant is built,
it becomes part of the energy
system for decades.
But our experience shows
that resistance is possible.
How?
By bringing into the conversation
the adverse impacts
and externalities of coal plants.
Secondly, also by providing
clean alternatives,
and more importantly,
by involving the local communities --
because they’re the first to be impacted,
and they must also have a seat
in the conversation.
In the last decade,
technology has moved at a fast pace.
It has lowered its costs dramatically.
Africa can, and must, develop
with all the energy it requires
without incurring
the disastrous impact of coal,
i.e. health and
environmental consequences.
Development and clean, breathable air
must not be mutually exclusive.
Thank you.